good evening I'm Papa Gloria I have
returned for Pugh news what's that we're
getting breaking news idubbbz
it's a simp that's impossible I don't
think I've seen the Internet
collectively lose their mind over
something in a very long time
so obviously I'm gonna talk about it
people dying of disease items Benson
let's talk about that this is a bit
awkward because I obviously I really
like items I don't know if I'm allowed
to call him a friend because we don't
really talk but I respect him a lot he's
a good dude I work with him and I think
a lot of people share this opinion that
I have on him if you enjoy my content at
least I would even go as far as say is
an important figure for the internet big
words
okay high pedestal so what happened what
happened with items to fall so far down
to the low disgusting despicable
unexplainable title of simp items and
simp those two things do not match i
dubs Chad I go to go boo go what's
happened well this whole thing started
about a week ago when items girlfriend
posted online that she was started and
only fans account for those two you
don't know what an only fans are
counties it's a website where people
discuss different political opinions
different literature I know I'm making
this joke only fans is basically where
you put either lewd photos of yourself
or straight up okay and you have to pay
for it
people pay that's the most outrageous
thing out of this whole thing I'm just
kidding this whole thing happened in a
timely manner after she got a boob job
okay interesting I'm very excited to
announce my lewd only fans account check
me out link below I'm very excited she's
very excited guys to provide cute
cosplay photo sets and more this is also
in another very timely matter of same
mean being just peak meme right now this
whole thing just could not have collided
more perfectly so now of course what do
people do
well they endlessly call idubbbz a
simple mine this has been going on for a
long time now let's hope that items
becoming a simp is what brings leafy
back from the dead alright I wouldn't go
that far
Sam babe it's 4 p.m. time for my only
famous photo shoot yes honey can I go
now I guess the fact that even items can
become a simp really makes me depressed
yeah the fact that even I end up
Hercules himself fell for wall man s mhm
I can't believe items Bridge Raiders by
becoming a sip himself people are
calling items the same that just proves
the word sympathy lost all its meaning
really you don't think so you don't
think it lost its meaning like any other
meme that gets popular online okay
boomer I thought simp was the person
that you know paid for the stuff but
didn't get any of the action I thought
that was the definition of the same like
the people that do anything for a woman
just in hope of something they'll pay
him they'll do they'll do their laundry
they'll wash the ranch they'll do
whatever okay I'm sorry I'm sorry he's
the same I'm joking I'm joking
it's it doesn't make any sense
I'm just saying per definition you're
false so people were naturally curious
what is idubbbz think about this very
supportive she responds I need to hear
this from the man himself I don't
believe it unless it comes out of M's
month okay if this is true
ian has to say the n-word at least three
times this cannot be real it was silent
for a week what is going on here guys a
week passes and items posted I'm done
I'm done no more mr. nice sin and of
course response simp clever you got him
good okay so then two weeks passes I
think and after the silence items has
finally uploaded a response video
shutting down his fans sex workers items
complaints addition decided to say it
didn't really fly well it's got a third
of the dislikes
I think it's safe to say that a lot of
people didn't really buy it so what
happened what do you say let's watch for
those of you were
unaware of the drama I recently brought
upon myself I'll fill you in to be fair
it was discovered that brought upon the
drama yeah you didn't do anything it's
not yeah it's not your fault it's not
your fault okay
I don't think Ian is exclusively looking
for a girl friends that wants to do only
fans to cast I be aware that would be a
weird King
anything from double penetration all the
way over to lewd cosplay and everything
in between and I think all of it is cool
yeah I know I I didn't think it would be
a controversial opinion either to be
fair I don't think it is controversial I
think says a lot of people engage with
it so we'd be pretty hypocritical to
have a problem with it are these people
that do preneur whatever are they're not
allowed to have a relationship I don't
think people are making that argument
either I think it's more the fact that
you people just don't want to date these
people I think that's isn't true but Ian
doesn't have a problem with it that
being said Ian acknowledges that most
people don't have an issue with it and
just making fun of in light of the
situation with memes good amount of
people are just doing the reasonable
thing and just making jokes and laughing
about it but then addresses the people
that are taking it a step further but
there's a whole nother group of people
who feel personally devastated and
betrayed you lied to us first of all I'm
not your [ __ ] dad disappointed either
this was like father to me I can't
believe this happened
Ian addresses one of the specific person
who's obviously this guy's like 15 isn't
making fun of kids I leave his job I
thought we were past this what happened
no shut the [ __ ] up you dumped him you
don't get the haha funny yourself out of
this one you're I mean it's funny but at
the same time and then addresses people
haven't been calling in a hypocrite
began saying that he has actually been
consistent with his views on women and
sex work during the years and showed
some example of that but I guess it's
out of sight out of mind it's not a
problem
you think these reasons would actually
do a smidgeon of research because like I
did it and I found the potential
hypocrisy in
I say in the past and it's it's pretty
[ __ ] consistent the funding for this
shirt is actually very very low tank
town pink town USA South corporate all
over the walls you know like I'm not
saying that women should be sterilized
or shouldn't be I'm just saying that
there is the market for it so it makes
sense that they would do it I would say
consume but never was that part of my
argument it's just flavor
it's just flavor because people I've
been put I saw some people post this for
example Europe or just admit it
your office where you yourself out
online you yourself out in front of your
family and your friends Europe or plain
and simple which isn't really an
argument it's just I think it's from the
green screen video that he'd that right
it's not him necessarily taking a stance
although it comes across as a thing you
then address another youtuber who made a
approach and a cons chart of why this is
a bad idea I wanted to talk more about
all the takes that people have and this
guy that we're gonna watch has pretty
much listed all of what okay okay
okay suppose nothing all right cons
everyone can see what he sees for a few
bucks well apparently she's making Bank
I need to do it Ian you need to remove
pedestal pedestal I'm pretty sure that's
not how you spell it
Internet is forever archive future jobs
question mark to be fair I'm pretty sure
anyone that makes the decision to put
nude photos of themselves online
deliberately have already weighed these
consequences you know like saying the N
word online deliberately same sort of
deal right which I would ever doubt
realistically what would the pros be I
haven't watched a video I don't know if
he actually leased at any I can imagine
it but you make money probably easily
easy easy you can work from home I'm not
saying it's super easy like got it like
a girls
I understand it's tough I understand but
you can work from home my job bc2 okay
you get to feel wanted and desired
that's nice I like that but then I think
I think that a lot of this boils down to
is that you sort
create an intimacy with other people
online generally in a relationship
having that intimacy for a lot of people
at least I would argue for most people
is something special that you to share
but it seems also like people are
projecting their fears that if they let
their girlfriend do something like this
then she will immediately start banging
other guys one day you know one day you
start an only fast account the second
day Ricardo comes knocking on your door
and and you become your wife's boyfriend
essentially I mean I'm not saying that's
gonna happen but the science is there we
have all the data it's gonna happen Ian
watch out for the card okay Conn's we
have everyone can see what he sees for a
few dollars what exactly do you think
I'm seeing do you think she's shooting
fireworks out of her post screening The
Matrix Reloaded down they're not a
mystery it's a tee dude and then there's
no special it doesn't become less
valuable the more people see it I mean I
think it's right in this sense if there
was past photos if there was past photos
it would not be less valuable but if its
current photos I would argue yes
my body and my person is the most value
list thing on the planet I think
[ __ ] and a guy being shirtless it's the
same things just to be fair just play
devil's advocate okay it hurts me to do
this Internet is a forever archive so
there's no I regret delete all button
that's not quite there I don't know why
this point yeah again they yeah I'm
pretty sure they waived these options
already I don't really see other people
having this concern for someone why do
you care that much about it really if I
had to politicize this whole thing I
would say that a lot of people that
washes idubbbz
throughout the years and enjoy his
content most of them probably have that
like this overly edginess tend to have
conservative views around relationships
that's just a majority standpoint which
obviously clashes hard against what he
even said in the beginning of what his
actual opinions are which he hasn't
apparently never really shared I find it
hard to believe that this many people
actually care deeply about this someone
else's relationship but I think it's
because it's idubbbz
the golden boy if this was anyone else
no one really would really
so after this video he makes up a couple
more points they were good I know I a
lot of its points I don't have a problem
with to be fair it's like everyone that
reacts to this is basically like well I
wouldn't like it from if my girlfriend
did that I would not be okay with that
him doing that but if he wants to do it
then I guess it's fine but people didn't
really buy this video people didn't
really buy his argument which is kind of
a unique thing because throughout the
years that he and it's just been
consistently putting out great arguments
that people can get by I mean he even
rationalized can n-word how do you do
that but he's also sticking out for his
girlfriend and this whole thing comes
across as a bit tad bit defensive it
felt a bit cherry-picked and I think
that's why a lot of people are pointing
out he seems like The Crying happy-face
voice I could be more or whatever it's
called falling you knew that there's a
hint of sadness people are detecting
people are good okay there's a hint of
sadness behind the ice in this video Ian
are you okay which is probably true for
someone that's been sucking drama you
know what we're seeing is just the tip
of the iceberg what Ian Ian's girlfriend
is going through is probably ten times
worse with people harassing digging
through old stuff private messaging all
these sort of stuff that kind of spirals
up over a long time yeah it's
frustrating I'd be pissed too and I
think that's why that's the reason why
he comes across as if he's pretending to
be okay with this when he really is not
another thing that people have been
saying is that items has been deleting
content but either it's made fun of
other people deleting content quickly
leaving comments chin a weight idubbbz
actually delete comment this one had 2k
likes I can see why you would think this
but from my experience I get so much
spam on my channel everyone that posts
the same comments will eventually get
switched out I don't think he's delaying
comments and if he was I think he's in
his right to do so because there's some
pretty harsh stuff about his girlfriend
here in the list stole art multiple
times
she stole art I don't know I don't like
these lists because even if it's true or
not it's such oh he already knows about
these things I don't think it's just
like what it doesn't feel fair to bring
this up in this context but it seems
like a lot of people share this
sentiment of her having only fence it's
the least of her worries
she's a pretty bad
person so people love idubbbz they don't
like his girlfriend basically so this
almost serves as a people are either
concern for idubbbz or that she was
gonna leave it in the future or people
are using this as a haha told you so in
the future when she leaves you for
Ricardo listen I can I wouldn't be okay
with it but I can I have to admit at
least Susak super adding some sort of
confidence by saying publicly that he's
okay with it
if he's truly you're fine with it who
cares who cares why do you care what's
the conclusion of this I think you know
it also goes down to whether it's right
or wrong for a person to do this to
share online naked photos of themselves
with whether that's a morally right or
wrong thing regardless if you do it
people are going to judge you for it
that's just the reality of the situation
so I don't think it matters to how Ian
responded to this it would have had the
same reaction regardless I think what he
should have done is what he said in the
video what am I gonna do you think I
should just like take a shot gun to her
head no it's time to die now yes that's
what you should have done the end I hope
you learn your lesson
I don't know what do you think clearly a
very controversial topic to talk about
smash like for return of puppy Gloria
subnautica symp not to care very much on
theme do you want to have a shirt that
says simp on it Ian fence check this out
five dollars of each purchase goes to
the ocean foundation a good course clean
ocean and I see you gamers tomorrow hey
go bye bye
you know what big peepees do they play
PewDiePie pixel ings of course pixel
ings is a creature collecting game I'm
the primary shareholder over a Brazilian
players have downloaded and it's got a
perfect score it's safe to say it's the
most popular game of all time pretty pie
pick slings it's awesome deal with it
deal with it
[Music]